openclaw use cases. So I just built a
website with over 500 openclaw use cases
and today I'm going to show you exactly
how to use it. This is organized by
category. Also shows you for example
who's using it, how to get access to it.
The prompt you can just copy and paste
to start automating with this task.
[music] And you can click between or
search inside this section to get over
500 use cases across 14 different
categories uh with 500 different copy
and paste prompts. And all of these have
proven case studies and links to example
[music] case studies as you can see
right here. So if you're looking for
real ways to use OpenClaw, this is one
of the best ways to do it. Most people
set up OpenClaw and then just kind of
stare at it. They have no idea what to
do with it. And that ends today. This
website's basically a cheat code because
you have over 500 real things you can
make open claw do for you right now. Not
someday today. Plus all the copy and
pasteable prompts to use it to with
links to example case studies for each
use case. So we're talking, for example,
building tools, running tasks,
automating your entire workflow, all
without writing a single line of code.
And the crazy part is most people open
have no idea any of this is even
possible. And that's exactly why we
built this. So today I'm going to talk
you through the whole setup, show you
how to find the right use cases for you,
and I can show you how we can test some
of them live together. So by the end of
this video, you're going to know exactly
how to make open claw 100 times more
powerful. So if we have a look at
openclaw and the setup right here
basically what you can see is that we've
split this into categories. So we've
researched all of the use cases. So for
example, if we have a look at this um
you can see that we've actually for
example taken the morning brief example
use case which is from this website
right which is looking at how people are
using openclaw and then what we've done
is we've created a prompt where you can
just implement that yourself right so if
you want to just uh steal this example
you can just copy and paste a prompt
then you can go over to open claw and
use this example case study um right
here. So, we can just paste our prompt
right here. And we can say, "Okay, every
day I see it 7 a.m. Send me a morning
brief with unread email summary, today's
calendar, [music] weather, and my top
three tasks, right? And then if I paste
in that example prompt into openclaw,
it's going to implement it right now."
Right? And that's basically how all of
this works. So, it's a really simple
setup, is super easy to use, and
basically you can just check out
whatever you want. So, for example, here
we could, for example, in inbox um and
declutter our emails, right? We could
turn our meeting notes to action items.
All of these prompts are examples of
real ways people are actually using
this. So, we even, for example, said
maintain my grocery list when I say add
um X, add it, group items by produce um
and whenever I ask, and give me the list
whenever I need it. Right? All sorts of
stuff. Now if we go to for example like
content creation, we can say okay
generate 20 YouTube video ideas for
niche channel include and then it will
just generate ideas for my channel right
here. And again we have links to the
actual case studies of people using this
stuff. Right. So for example here I
actually linked to Matthew Burman's
article where he talks about how to use
this sort of stuff and if you need like
more information on that particular
topic or if you want to just dive deeper
into it. Right. So it's a pretty amazing
tool. Basically, the way that I built
it, just to be 100% transparent with
you, is I went into Claude and just said
like, "Give me 500 use cases of how
people can use AI and and what it
works." Let me try and find the original
chat here. Yeah. So, this is basically
how we built it. Like, just so you know
how to build your own version if you
wanted to. So, we said like, "Find me
500 use cases for OpenClaw." And then a
lot of the links came back super
generic. The links weren't correct for
most of them. And then from there, we
gave it more ideas, more briefing on how
to do it. Added a CTA to our community
on top of it. And then um also created a
full step-by-step guide on on what Open
Claw is and that sort of thing. And then
once you've done that, once you've
generated a website like you can see
right here with the 500 use cases, you
can just click on share artifacts and
that's how you can create an awesome
website like this, whatever tool you
want to learn about. So if you want to
get the full details on that, we've
actually got it for free. If you want to
get access to this website, it's
completely free inside the AI success
lab link in the comments description. So
just go to the classroom and then you
would go to this section here, the March
2026 version and you can just get access
right there. Click on that link and it
takes you directly to the website where
you can just search through and use it
however you want to. So if you're
wondering, okay, what are the best
skills, the best use cases, how it
works, etc. It's all right here for you
for free. So that's basically it for me.
Thanks very much for watching today.
That is 500 use cases on how OpenAI
works. If we have a look at the main use
cases here, so you got like productivity
and admin, developer and coding, content
creation, research and learning, uh
marketing and SEO is a big big one. So
I'd recommend checking out that. That's
probably one of the most useful
sections. Communication and messaging,
you got smart home and personal life.
This is quite interesting as well cuz
like a lot of people are using this for
their personal life too, not just for
like business related stuff. And you can
see some examples of prompts um and how
people using this with uh links to case
studies and everything else. We've also
got stuff for example for like community
and social data and analytics automation
integration like you can actually this
is quite interesting. So for example if
you want to create sub agents we have a
prompt for it right here with examples
of how it works. And you can see here
the prompt is like root task to
specialized agents coding task to
whatever and you can separate your open
claw into different agents depending on
the work um required. So that's all
inside here with advanced prompts and
and copy and pasteful use cases as you
can see. So thanks so much for watching.
Appreciate it. If you haven't already,
feel free to check out the AI profit
boardroom. This is my AI automation
community where we really deep dive on
stuff like open call link in the
comments description or just go to the
AI profitaboom.com. This really focus on
helping you save time and scale we
automation. So for example, we have a
daily accountability group where you can
post your goals, stay accountable um and
make sure you avoid information overload
plus see what other people working on
which is great. We have a weekly update
post. So each week I condense my 60
hours of re research into what's good
and what you can safely ignore to save
your time. You can post questions inside
the community, get help and support
whenever you need to. And then also
inside the calendar here, you can jump
on weekly video calls, get help and
support in real time. These are Zoom
meetings where you can actually meet the
community as well. Inside the map, you
can actually zoom in on your local area
and meet cool people in your area, which
is awesome. Then inside the classroom,
you can get all of my best training. So,
for example, you can go from beginner to
expert with AI automation and learn how
to build your first AI agent in under
five minutes. Additionally, inside the
classroom, you can get my best playbooks
on, for example, how to automate X,
newsletters, shorts, AI avatar videos,
and everything else. Additionally, you
can get my daily updates. So, inside
this section, we update this with all
the new updates. So recently, for
example, today we created a new training
on open AI uh openclaw AI SEO lobster
board 500 openclaw use cases. You can
see we've already covered a video on
chat GBT 5.3 instant and Gemini 3.1
flashlight. These came out today and we
just cover them as soon as we can with a
video tutorial and a step-by-step guide
so you can implement and learn how to
use this stuff yourself. And we do that
every single day, right? Um also inside
the classroom here, you can learn how to
get more clients with the agency course.
You can watch about the coaching calls
over here. You can connect with me
personally. So you can actually direct
message me personally inside here. And
then you can learn how to rank inside
Google AI search engines with this
section and how to grow a YouTube
channel with AI based on what's working
for me. So that's all inside the AI
profit boardroom. Thanks for watching
and I'll see you on the next one.
Cheers.